congrats us carter ghost rider
you paid the right price so we just made
your hits tighter
blue ivy carter honors her famous dad
jay-z by wrapping a few of his famous
lines
this makes me proud in a pre-recorded
tribute video for her dad that was
played during his induction into the
rock and roll hall of fame last month
nine-year-old blue joined her mom
beyonce and 30 other celebs who each
recited a jay-z lyric gather round
hustlers because it's about to go
down
yeah stars like halle berry kevin hart
lena waith common regina king lenny
kravitz john legend rashida jones kerry
washington chris martin jamie foxx
rihanna lupita nyong'o pharrell williams
ed sheeran samuel l jackson lin-manuel
miranda david letterman and way way more
lent their voices to the montage allow
me to reintroduce myself my name is hov
h to the ov as for blue she shared a
censored version of jay's 1999 track
ride or die
congrats us carter ghost rider
you paid the right price so we just made
your hits tighter
i mean how cute is that i'm very happy
the video was shared shortly after the
ceremony honoring the 2021 inductees
aired saturday on hbo former president
barack obama also made an appearance he
shared the significance of the grammy
winners track dirt off your shoulder
[Music]
in his own life i've turned to jay-z's
words at different points in my life
whether
i was brushing dirt off my shoulder on
the campaign trail or
sampling his lyrics on the edmund pettus
bridge on the 50th anniversary of the
selma march to montgomery
today jay-z is one of the most renowned
artists in history and an embodiment of
the american dream comedian dave
chappelle was there to introduce jay
telling the audience that while he is
being inducted into the rock and roll
hall of fame he will always be a part of
the hip-hop community
it is an incredible honor
to induct this next man into the rock
and roll hall of fame
but i need everybody in rock and roll to
know
that even though you are honoring him
he is ours
he is hip-hop
but back to
blue just last month she crashed her
famous parents date night in a video
celebrating tiffany and company
[Music]
when it comes to jay-z and beyonce
that's hardly the first time the two
have collaborated over their
20-year-long relationship
[Music]
and there's more of that musical
goodness
[Music]
and
[Music]
and when eti caught up with jay in
august he opened up about why he loves
working with his wife she's uh
super um
detail oriented obviously as you can see
from her work and she's uh incredibly
hard worker
super talented
very inspiring
[Music]
you